نبقى في الايطالي ذاته فالضربه التي نفذت
على منشات في اصفهان الايرانيه والتي
تحدثت وسط جورنال عن ان اسرائيل تقف خلفها
تحمل الكثير من الخبايا
طاهر تزامن مع زياره المرشد الايراني
لمعرض الانجازات الصناعيه التي تضمن
بالتحديد انجازات الطائرات المسيره
قولها ان الهجوم سجل نجاحا هائلا خلافا
لمزاعم النظام الايراني اما يدعوك احر نود
فقالت ان الضربه تستهدفت منشاه حساسه تعمل
فيها ايران على تطوير صواريخ فرض صوتيه
والمفاجاه هنا بحسب الصحيفه ان المشروعه
تم
بمساعده الروسيه
وقالت ان هدفها هو تعطيل محاولات العوده
الى الاتفاق النووي نقطه اخرى مهمه في هذه
الضربه وهي تعليق ميخائيل بودليات مستشار
رئيس الاكرانيا عن ان منطقه الحرب في
اوكرانيا لا يرحم وقاتل وانها تحاسب
المتواطئين في اشاره لتزويد ايران لروسيا
بالمسيرات ايران غضبت بشده من هذا التصريح
واعتبرته عدائيا واستدعت القائم بالاعمال
الاوكراني لديها للاحتجاج بل وهدد مسؤول
ايراني اوكرانيا بموقف سياسيا مختلف من
الحرب القائمه على اراضيها اذا لم تصحح
هذه التصريحات العدائيه